it might look like everyone knows how to
start maze farming in Ghana okay but
don't fall into that drop did you know
that Ghana has the worst yield of maze
in the whole world not too Pleasant to
accept but that is the fact Ghana has an
average yield of 1.7 metric tons per
hectare compared to other countries on
this same continent getting about 6 to 7
metric tons per hect amidst of that
though it's actually possible to become
rich with maze farming business in Ghana
if you do things right people in Ghana
following these Tech techniques are
making over 22,000 GH cities of
consistent profit from their two AC maze
farm and I will teach you how to start
yours today and get similar Ys also do
you know why right now is the best time
to start me farming well field
experiments were conducted to determine
the optimum time for planting maze in
the various ecological zones and seasons
of Ghana in order to achieve the best Ys
it turns out made match and made
planting give the best yield guys the
best time is almost passing and that is
why I making this video right now in
Ghana maze is cultivated during two main
growing Seasons from January to May and
from June to late September it is found
that every September October and
February March demand for Maze goes
extremely high and that is when farmers
can potentially make huge money out of
their maze farm this is obvious because
during these periods maze is not grown
due to the climate and at the end of
this video I will show you how to use
this to your advantage and double your
revenue from your maze farm so now that
you know this is the best time to start
let's go ahead and talk about the best
practices on how to start your maze farm
and get the most out of it step by step
for the marketing aspect I'll share my
top four secret in selling my maze with
E and get the optimum prices at the end
of this video so smash that subscribe
button and let's dive in the first step
in maze farming in general is to acquire
the best piece of land for your maze
cultivation how large the size of land
should be depends on you but I recommend
getting a large piece of land if you
really mean business however if you only
have a small piece of land it shouldn't
stop you from doing something preferably
get a deep Bine structured well erated
well drained Lomi soil type of land that
are rich in organic matter this is
proven to give the highest yeld R
plantations okay choosing the land isn't
difficult at all once you have settled
on the land it's time to start preparing
the land for cultivation one mistake
people keep doing in their Farms is they
jump straight to planting whatever they
want to plant without preparing the soil
first the well-being of your crops
largely depends on the conditions under
which they are cultivated taking one to
two weeks to prepare the soil before
planting will go a long way to improve
the Y and health of your crops but how
do you actually prepare the soil it is
actually simple remember I mentioned the
recommended soil requirement for Maze
earlier a deep fine structured well
erated well drained Lomi soil by soil
preparation this is what you want to
achieve start by tilling or plowing the
soil this makes the soil lose and become
fine structured well erated and well
drained this ensures better growth and
development of the seed into a mature
plant if it is not raining often during
the time of cultivation you should
probably consider irrigating the soil
for about 1 to 2 weeks before sewing the
seeds remember regardless of the soil
type and the land you secure for your
business it should go through these same
preparation stages once this is done you
should go ahead and choose your
preferred type of seed there are two
main type of seeds that are grown in
Ghana the hybrid or the yellow corn and
the local seed or opv now if you mean
business then I recommend the hybrid
seats mainly because it has proven to
give the highest yield in Ghana and it
is drought resistant also which means
that it can still thrive in the midst of
our weird and unpredicted weather the
hybrid cost around 300 to 500 cities per
acre depending on where you find
yourself within the country if you are
going with a hybrid seat though you
should never recycle the seats and new
seats should be contained each year the
reason is that these seeds are
manufactured such that after you
cultivate and harvest you can't grow the
seeds again if you do it's either the
seeds will rot in the soil or will
germinate but cannot grow well you need
to buy new seeds every year and once
your seeds are ready and your land is
prepared let's go ahead and learn how to
sew the seeds in order to get the best
yield plant your seeds at a depth of
about 1.5 to 2 in in the soil now
optimal density varies but it is is
generally recommended to plant 18,000 to
30,000 plants per acre depending on the
specific maze variety maze is a warm
season crop plant seeds when the soil
temperature reaches at least 50° f for
proper germination the best temperature
for germination is 75° F or 24° C
population of maze plants on a piece of
land is also an important determiner of
the plant Health adequate Road spacing
is essential for proper air circulation
and sunlight exposure the recommended
spacing is typically between 30 to 40 in
now let's talk about one of the most
essential aspects of me farming that you
should probably know if you want to make
a difference you can't succeed in maze
farming business today if you don't know
about effective weed and Pest Control
techniques the fall army worm is your
greatest enemy in maze farming business
this pest can cause you a loss of more
than 50% in your business from studies
the estimated mean National yield loss
due to fall worm in Ghana was over
470,000 tons in 2018 with a monetary
value of over 1.7 million us fori is a
poly fagos and highly mobile migratory
insect pest which was first detected in
West Africa in early 2016 since its
introduction this insect has
significantly impacted livelihoods of
small scale Farmers across the continent
and in Ghana in particular you can
actually plant like 10 acres of land in
Ghana and get just half of it at the end
because of these Devils it is possible
to control them but expensive here is
how you do it after 4 weeks of
germination start visiting your F
frequently and look for signs of
infestation this ensures that you detect
it early as it is key in preventing
excessive loss once you see few plant
infested there are three classes of
pesticides that are proven to be very
effective against fall am the first
group is the spinos signs this class of
insecticide work by disrupting the tinic
acolin receptors of the insect's nervous
system this mechanism of action makes
this class of insecticide very selective
in destroying the target insect and
leaving the beneficial Predators this is
very helpful as it doesn't kill all the
microorganisms in the soil as part of
the target insect phos science does not
destroy only mature insects but also
their lava and eggs some examples of
spinos sign insecticides are entrust and
success new we also have the tin Ben it
works by penetrating the leaf tissues
and forming Reservoir within treated
leaves which provide residual activity
against past that ingest the plant
substance when feeding example of imin
Benz you can use to control for L are
affirm and proclaim the last class of
insecticide I personally find effective
against foram worm is the fantron Pro
Group chanton Pro binds to a specific
receptor in the muscles called the
ryanodine receptor when the chemical
binds to this receptor it causes muszle
cells to leak calcium the musles stop
working normally the insect is paralyzed
and dies some examples of this group are
alore and coragen once you have your
insecticide figured out spray your farm
at least once in 3 weeks depending on
the particular insecticide you get this
is essential because for Lami worm is
very persistent and migrates so quickly
from Farm to farm for instance if you
treat your farm and there is a nearby
Farm that is infested to well expect to
see your farm infested again as soon as
the chemical loses its power this is why
you need to keep treating the farm until
the plant start to Silk at this stage if
your farm isn't heavily infested already
the plant will be healthy until you
harvest even without additional
treatments maze takes about 12 to 16
weeks to reach maturity as you may need
to spray the farm at least three times
in 3 weeks interval depending on how
persistent your farm gets infested no
that I am unable to recommend any dosage
of the chemical since I do not know what
specific agrochemical you get I advise
that you use it as prescribed by the
chemist at the shop you buy it now with
weed control if your farm can be weeded
manually it is perfect as you would not
need to worry about the effect of
herbicides on your farm however if
that's not possible depending on the
size of your farm you may still have
options like post emerence herbicides
the last thing you would want to do is
to sew your seats let let it germinate
and ignore it to stay in the bushes maze
hate weeds as it suppresses its growth
and health weeds in your farm will also
bring in several pests to make sure that
your hard work is roomed so where your
options if labor cost for weeding will
be too much in your situation consider
using a preemergence herbicides on the
piece of land before sewing your seeds
to prevent germinated weed seedlings
from becoming established also consider
using post Emer cze to control weed in
your farm after they have already
emerged from the soil there are
postemergence herbicides specifically
made for Maze and other narrow Le crops
designed to Target and Destroy both
grasses and broadlea weeds leaving all n
Le plant healthy some examples of these
abdes are Nico gold Amin spray and Mason
now if you followed up till now and
going to implement what you've learned
so far I am confident that you are 80%
more likely to succeed in this business
the last step I will talk about before
diving into the business aspect is
fertilization as more and more plants
and crops or even weeds grow on a piece
of land the soil gradually loses its
nutrients for example for every ton of
whole plant corn Harvest we remove from
the soil about 25 kg of nitrogen 5 kg of
phosphorus and 20 kg of potassium that
means if you want to regrow maze or
anything on that land the coming years
you would need to replace these lost
nutrients in order to have a
satisfactory corn yield for the years to
come as a rule of thumb you may need to
supplement about 100 kg of nitrogen 280
kg of phosphorus and 100 kg of potasium
per hectar in order to achieve this
however it's very important to
understand which nutrients is necessary
for the plant growth and at which stage
otherwise if you apply a nutrient at the
wrong time you may har your CR instead
the two main fertilizers strategies you
may want to consider for your maze Farm
are the basal fertilization and folar
fertilization basil application
fertilizers are applied near the base of
the sewn seed usually one day before or
after sewing for Maze the most important
nutrients necessary at this early stage
is phosphorus therefore you may need to
apply fertilizers with large amount of
phosphorus and a little of both nitrogen
and potach get for example a fertilizer
with NPK value of
535 and varry about 5 to 10 G of this
fertilizer 2 in below and 2 in beside
each hole containing two seeds after
this the next fertilization will be at
the stem elongation stage this stage
begins about 5 to 6 weeks after
germination this corn grow stage can
predict the number of grains that will
develop in each given cup grow at this
stage of the plant grow corn needs the
most nitrogen along with plenty of water
and other nutrients it is therefore
important to this time apply a
fertilizer with a higher n nitrogen
content for example one with NPK value
of
355 now note that this is not the only
way to go about it you may have other
ways you have done this and would love
to know about it in the comment section
what have taught you so far has proven
to be effective and has been replicated
by many farmers across the country I am
confident it will give you same result
if you follow it carefully now the sales
or the marketing aspect the first
question to ask is how is M used in GH
research says that Ghana's M production
mainly goes into livestock feed and
household consumption with this in mind
here are the four most effective ways to
sell your maze with ease but before that
if you have gained value in this video
so far would you please help me by
subscribing to the channel right now
okay thank you for doing that number one
is food processes have you thought about
the fact that almost every Chop Bar and
restaurant across all the regions in
Ghana procur some amount of maze for
their daily operations the only thing it
takes to start working with these
business entities is reaching an agreed
price that works for both of you if you
able to reach a better deal with them
they will definitely turn their backs on
all previous suppliers and start working
with you this doesn't necessarily mean
settling for low prices however
compromising a little in your price and
getting huge amount of sales will still
bring that cash you want in your pocket
the second way to sell your maze in
Ghana is through local markets local
markets and retail shops are another
great way to get your maze into the
market these are the places people T to
when they need home staff and food staff
urgently that is a good opportunity to
showcase your produce to a lot of people
who can potentially be customers that is
as simple as that the third one though
is livestock feed males as I mentioned
earlier livestock feed is one major area
the Ghan maze go into you should start
by researching in your area or even
other localities you can transport your
ma to for livestock feed males and Petry
feed males there are several of them in
Kumasi such as ASV Agro limited Boris
Farm Supplies Pria poultry and more a
lot also in Acra such as aquaba feeds
limited the lawin Farms limited amas
Farms limited and more these meals are
looking for best deals that will promote
their businesses also go to them and
reach an agreement with them and start
supplying them your maze the last one
and definitely not the least is
exploring farming contract Arrangements
this is where you enter into agreement
with Buyers to supply a specific
quantity of maze at a predetermined
price regardless of the Season price
fluctuations in the Maze industry is a
real problem during the rainy season
when maze is grown a lot the price of
maze comes down and during the dry
season when it is not grown a lot in the
country the prices s so high this is a
problem for the companies using maze for
their Productions as they may need to
also fluctuate their prices from season
to season again remember every problem
is an opportunity tap into this
opportunity by reaching a standard price
and quantity you are willing to supply
them all the time regardless of the
season and almost every company will be
willing to work with you but if you can
do all of these effectively it boils
down to one thing effective planning
watch this video on how to write and
execute a business plan for your farm
step by step